well I'm excited to speak to you um I
got a chance to watch the first two
episodes and I love what I see so
congratulations on the show and I've
been seeing that it's been a lot of
positive reviews as well so I hope you
guys are taking it all in bless we are a
day at a time an hour at a time
seriously
all right so sadika I'll start with you
now reality shows about large families
are always so appealing to viewers and
obviously you guys have merged culture
religion Hollywood and that's really
what makes your show so appealing but
it's also female dominated so how
excited are you to Showcase all the girl
power on the show we are so excited you
know growing up we grew up in a very
patriarchal society especially given our
background in Afghanistan education and
to be able to be like break the stigma
and The Stereotype and say this is what
Afghan women and American America our
story are like and to be able to share
our journey it makes us feel good
because I know that there's people out
there that can relate to it and that's
the most important thing is to
share the story The Journey and say hey
you know what you might not be the only
one going through this now
um noria for you I'll ask because you're
you're really doing
um a lot in the investment business and
so obviously you guys are on Hulu the
Kardashians are on Hulu right you guys
are a large family they're a large
family so the comparisons have already
started are you guys hoping to follow in
their footsteps footsteps as far as
expanding your likeness and your
businesses beyond the scope of reality
television and really using this
platform to take your family to the next
level I think well we would love to use
our platform to help give back which is
why we have our charity Baraka and
yearly we hold fundraisers and it's for
last year it was for Refugee women and
children the year before it was for
victims in Afghanistan so that's
definitely something that we want to
focus on as a family is how we can bang
together and get back back so that's I
think goal number one now Hamida as the
youngest sister of the bunch
um what were you what would you say you
admire about you know your older sisters
who are I guess you guys have
um to find them as a bit more
conservative and where would you say you
guys clash in the middle oh well I think
obviously because it or the wolf pack
where the young were the ones that were
born were the trifecta there's two more
eight nine ten and then there's the
Elder sisters who were born in
Afghanistan and they have a very
different mentality and we just have to
be a little bit more filtered around
them and that's where the Clash comes in
this is what the with the culture and
our identities the cultural expectations
of how we should conduct ourselves are
you guys prepared for
um some people who may not be positively
receptive to the show because of all of
the
um cultural stipulations that people may
may expect you guys to have um in
addition obviously to marrying the
religious aspect of it I just think for
us it's so important just to be to speak
Our Truth and this is our individual
Journeys we're not representing you know
know a whole country or an Arab studying
all Muslims this is our family these are
our struggles this is how we're
balancing our culture what our daily
lives and just being authentic yes
absolutely now um we get a sneak peek of
of your mom on the show we see her kind
of sprinkled throughout how was it
getting her to get on board with being
on camera and understanding what you
guys are going to be doing as far as
being reality starts now so it was a
challenge because we we respect and love
our mother Heaven is beneath her feet
and she's not one to ever be in the
public eye she's very conservative she
speaks very few words and when she
speaks it's like wisdom and we how to we
had to be vulnerable in front of her we
had to have tough conversations with her
and those were conversations that we had
to have in front of her and then also
deal with the consequences of those
conversations after filming so it was a
bit challenging but it was also so
something new we learned about ourselves
and you know we have like this we have
to be one way in front of mom and one
way in front of ourselves when we're
trying to break that and we want to just
be ourselves all the time but with the
culture and the religion there just has
to be that respect and that boundary so
it's it's still challenging
mom is very excited though
she supports it trust me you can never
get her to do something she doesn't want
to do so she supports us
now has your guys's living situation
changed since filming rep for the show
because obviously the you guys filmed
this a while ago and now
um it's airing so are there still
sisters living in I think it was four
sisters living in the house in one of
the houses there was at one time um
because Robia was staying with us so we
still live together we're still in the
world yeah and um I still love you has
her own place now I still live by myself
and she of course with her husband and
then continues with her husband and her
kids and Malika's still in London so the
living situations are the same for the
most part you guys
um making sure that you make that you
maintain your close Bond
um as you embark on this journey because
as you said you have to relive a lot of
these moments as you watch them back
which can be I guess you know I don't
want to say retraometry housing but it
can re you have you have to rehash it
when you're watching these things back
think that you may have already
reconciled or healed from and then
you're adding the world's opinions
um into whatever you guys have already
dealt with and reconciled it can be a
bit emotional sometimes we yesterday
um all uh half of us got together and
binged it and it was funny just kind of
reliving those scenes and what happened
and just the commentary were like wait
well you said that I didn't know you
said that and then we'll like hear the
confessionals and we're seeing it all
for the first time so at the end of the
day it's all love we just keep an open
line of communication we did and we made
a path you know prior to the show airing
like we're still sisters what was said
was said we're still family and we just
kind of stick to that code like no
matter what we're always going to be
there for each other there has been ups
and downs but we believe firmly in just
you know connecting and because blood is
thicker than drama yes it is
what will you say are also the
differences
um with the if any if any
um between the older more conservative
sisters and the wolf pack in the way in
which they handle romantic relationships
because I would imagine that
um there's a there can be a stark
contrast there oh there's a huge
contrast there and Khadijah has been
with her husband for about 18 years he's
her first love really and
muzlifa married her husband what at 19.
at 19 after meeting him three times she
had a very Islamic you know approach to
her marriage and she said the same way
and you know we
I don't know how I mean like so we
believe in dating but with the older
sisters it was the guy you're dating
first or last is the guy you're going to
marry yeah and so they were dating to
marry off the bat and you know we date
to have fun sometimes that's a really
big contract we don't want the pressure
of thinking about am I gonna marry this
guy yeah dating is already hard enough
and every time we bring the guy on are
you gonna marry him are you going to
marry him we're like no when the woman
just me wet my feet a little bit Yeah
and with them it's like oh we've been
talking to him you must marry him so I
don't know that's the biggest difference
and overall what are you hoping that
viewers take from your family we want to
really just display that
it is a big family it is a roller
coaster ride and we do come from a very
unique situation but we want to utilize
our platform to do good like Maria was
saying earlier and we want to just break
the stigma that people have on Muslim
American women that you have to look a
certain way you have to act a certain
way and it's just frankly not true and
we're the prime example of that well
well done I look forward to watching the
rest of the seasons
we'll get a season two thank you we hope
so thank you so much nice to meet you so
I will start with you Shakur obviously
out of the 10 Sisters You Are The Proud
leader of the wolf pack
um you consider yourself the protector
of the whole family but really the
spearheadter of the younger group of the
bunch so you're already you've already
been in entertainment so this far away
into reality television is I would
assume right up your alley so how has
your work thus far prepared you for this
moment and how much did you try and
prepare your sisters for this world that
you've already been living in I've been
skin
and really just being able to
disassociate yourself from the real
world and what happens in the
entertainment world and being able to
just not listen to the static to be able
to really just stay laser focused and
keep your eye on the price and to not
get distracted and I feel like I
definitely try to implement that in my
sister's lives and tell them how
impaired how imperative it is for them
to do so but it's just kind of like
trial and error you don't really know
how to prepare for it unless you go
through something yourself you can tell
someone something and they can
sympathize with you but until you go
through it it doesn't have that same
gravitas you know what I mean so I feel
like basically and stay true to yourself
you know you don't snap for something to
fall for anything just have your
boundaries have your have your limits
now knowing the ins and outs of the
business where there are major
hesitations for you and your family to
enter into this space oh sure you're
always um concerned of
how everyone's going to interact with
each other uh heads bumping they're
being friction uh people seeing just how
crazy you guys really are you know the
dysfunction that every family has we
just happen to actually reveal our
dysfunction and you just don't know how
people are going to perceive it you know
you have people are either going to like
it or love it but
I feel like you just kind of have to
just stay in your truth stay in your
truth and be authentic and I feel like
everything kind of works itself out
Janelle for you what do you feel as if
your family brings to this oversaturated
space of reality television that hasn't
necessarily been seen or done before
point out that there's many things right
first who are like the first Afghan
American Family on television number 10
sisters uh cut from the same cloth and
you know this story really taught it
showcases you know us you know in two
different worlds of tradition and modern
modernism and as walking that fine line
with all you know being between two
cultural identities
um you know and secrets and Sisterhood
shows that Journey for us sisters
um and along all of that you know
everyone is raw authentic and real and
um every sister has a story that someone
out there can relate to for you again
how do you feel as if you guys are
prepared to stay grounded
um as the S10 sisters as a tight-knit
family you know continuing to kind of
navigate these two worlds as you're now
adding in Hollywood to all of this I
think a lot of that comes from just you
know either you're grounded or you're
not and that's something that was always
taught to us from time we were for
children and I think a lot of that has
to do with our faith that is our core
and everything else comes into that but
we have our sister meetings we we check
each other
um you know there are moments where you
you forget the cameras are rolling and
you know
um then you kind of like okay wow I'm
looking at myself almost in the mirror
and you see those things but through all
of this I feel like we're all we're
always ever evolving now Shakur I think
there are going to be a lot of
um
puns because your name is Shakur right
you were a rapper from what I from what
I know
and obviously we have you know we have
Tupac Shakur who is a cultural icon in
itself in him in himself and he was just
inducted into the Hollywood Walk of Fame
so I felt like this show has really come
at a perfect time for you all are you
100 done with the music industry or are
you hoping that um you can kind of
dabble a bit more into it now that you
have this platform as well you know what
I'm open for whatever blessings and
opportunities come my way I'm never
gonna just say no I'm completely against
or for because you never know things
change from day to day a great situation
may present itself to where you're like
you know what I'm in the vibe it's a
good team you know everything's a
collaborative effort so if you find
someone to make magic with and on any
level I feel like you should pursue that
endeavor so for me I always have the
love for music I've had such a strong
background in it before it was a popular
thing to do before it was a saturated
Market when it was hard to get a record
deal where there was no social media
where you had to get it on just talent
and Merit without any you know things
that or gimmicks or stuff like that like
it was just a whole nother Beast so I
will always have that love and
appreciation for music and I wouldn't be
opposed to it if it came up but I'm just
not in the zone of like chasing it like
I used to do like it was like this is
what I'm doing and I was sick I was like
no if it comes cool I'll accept it thank
you God but if it doesn't I'd be
perfectly fine I'm more so focused on my
acting and Jamila um there's going to be
a lot of comparisons too because you
guys are a large family it's it's a lot
of girl power in this show which we're
excited to see
um there's a lot of beauty you all are
very beautiful ladies and you know
there's another big family that's out
there so how are you guys
prepared to handle the um comparisons to
probably the Kardashian family now that
you guys are here you know we're all
about women empowering other women and
supporting other people's successes you
know um they're definitely Trailblazers
in this industry and paved away so I
think it's great I mean we're excited to
be on Hulu and you know we're we're here
as a lot of sisters are here just to
tell their story uh bring a different
perspective show cultural uh you know
you know just social our culture uh and
show our world herself so
that's what we want to do and expanding
upon the culture of conversations
there's a lot of misconceptions about
um you know the Muslim faith and
specifically how that relates to you
guys in this background
um with your family being of
afghanistanian afghanistanian descent
what are you looking to dispel with this
show and within your specific lifestyle
with this specific series you know we're
not here to like we're telling our story
but we're not representing every Afghan
African-American woman out there we're
not representing the entire you know
Muslim Nation we're just showing that
we're a family that is Muslim but we
live our lives the way we do right and
we're Guided by our faith but this is
our take on it and
um Shakur you want to add to that yeah
it's just that we're not going to
we're not advocating for a specific
group of people or specific religious
faith of people it's just a glimpse into
our lives from our perspective and
showing people what we went through and
just the journey taking someone on a
journey I mean there's going to be a lot
of people who you know may not agree
with it there might be people who do
agree with it there's something out
there for somebody where they can say
wow I definitely went through this and
not just in the you know Afghan culture
and islamically this is across just
religious face in general people who are
extremists in every religion you know
and people who are there's just like
there's there's
more there's so many different diasporas
you know what I mean first generation
Americans who have immigrant families
that will be able to say you know what
we had to do these transitions to we had
to walk the fine line and balance of
Life of keeping culture alive and trying
to please our parents but still staying
true to ourselves and I feel like people
any denomination would be able to relate
to that in some kind of shape or form if
you're a first generation and you know
one of the things that people probably
assume is oh you're not educated or you
know you're you know you're you're
oppressed and you know women in our
culture are revered and obviously we
know what's going on in the social
climate in Afghanistan but you know
we're here to also show the world that
African-American women you know are are
educated and we're here and we're doing
what we need to do to
to basically survive I mean that's what
we've done our entire lives is started
from the bottom and we just keep working
working working and see where it goes
wow you ladies are doing a great job um
I look forward to watching the rest of
the season play out and hopefully we get
a season two because you guys are adding
a lot of spice to the reality television
world so yeah so congratulations on the
show
um obviously people are very excited
about it it's a large family there are a
lot of cultural things to be um exposed
and explained in this show things that
we haven't necessarily seen before so
congratulations again
um and I've already spoken to your
sister so I already know all of the
spice that you guys bring in addition to
to watching um the first two episodes
and how have you been taking in all of
the reactions from people who've already
watched the few the first few episodes
of the show you know uh those who are
close to me have watched it and they've
been very supportive
um very excited for us
um you know we're blessed to have this
opportunity to showcase who we are as a
family a family of 10 women so it's been
it's been great there are times that we
did say don't read all the comments you
know what I mean so sometimes it's okay
to not read all the comments um just
because you know you
we've worked very hard for this and
who wants to you don't need Debbie
downers
you know there's going to be people who
have their own opinion and they're
entitled to it and I'm entitled to not
respond
now this throughout the show we get to
see a lot of um you guys's culture being
you know your be with your parents and
the first half of you guys being born
and raised in Afghanistan versus the
second half being more modern and
Americanized because um your family had
already come to America so we get to see
a lot of not cultural divide which is
cultural differences between the sisters
so I was one of the older sisters on the
series
um versus the younger ones despite you
guys is clashing at times your
experience has been very different what
would you say you admire about your
younger sisters who aren't considered to
be as conservative as the older ones I
respect my younger sisters you know
they're well educated well spoken
they still follow you know the religion
you know they still are Muslim they you
know they fast they pray
you know maybe they dress a little clad
and that's okay you know I'm not gonna
judge you I'm you know I'm not a judger
that's that's God's place you know so I
respect that I respect their ambition
um and the respect they have for my
mother
our mother
um that's really important to me to
never lose sight of respect because that
is huge in our faith and our culture and
so the fact that they haven't lost that
um does give me Solace you know just
because you're born in America you're
still children of refugees and you
understand the hardship that they
endured to come to this country and to
give us a better life and so just to
always humble ourselves so sometimes you
just gotta be like humility goes a long
way
so yeah now as a woman who's Guided by
her faith were you nervous about
Bridging the Gap between
um Faith culture and entertainment what
type of reservations did you have before
agreeing to appear on a reality series I
consider myself the bridge between the
younger sisters and the older sisters
because I do like to go out with them
and whatnot but I may not dress the same
I may not participate in all the
activities but also have a good time
with them and then when I'm with my
older sisters you know I kind of know
the rules like when you go to their
homes they gotta dress accordingly and
you know and I'm okay with that I'm
completely okay with that because to me
it's a respect level
um what was the rest of your question I
still apologize I was just saying were
you nervous about
um Bridging the get between the two
worlds and doing so on a grand scale
like a reality series I was the only
thing that I truly was concerned about
was I did not want anything to divide us
I wanted to for us to be United and
stand as a united front
um some of the secrets I did not find
out until I saw the show so some of them
because I wasn't in that you know I
wasn't there taping
um so some of the you know some of the
secrets were kind of eye-opening for me
um but at the end of the day I support
my sisters and what they do and stand by
them because as an older sister I want
to lead by example and let you know that
no matter what you do I will still love
you I will still stand behind you
um there are things that maybe you know
I'm not in a whole agreements with and
that's okay but I am not here to judge
life is about taking risks we have a
variety of personalities that you've
probably noticed yes and we definitely
had you know some reservations about
being in the public eye
but we believe our Unity you know can
surpass any obstacles now this is um a
family unit that we've never seen before
as I mentioned you guys are really
showcasing a different side of a family
that have a family culturally
religiously how imperative is this
representation for you and your family
and others who may look and have similar
experiences to you guys but have never
seen themselves on television before in
this way so this is our story our
journey of ten sisters we truly are not
trying to be representative of all
Muslim people of all afghans
where we just want to share our journey
and our path as children of refugees and
this is what we have gone through this
is what this is real life for us this is
our truths and so we're really not
trying to represent
everyone
um there are people that I know will
have similar stories that have not had
the opportunity to share them you know
there are people that have told me like
wow like you guys you guys opened up and
you guys were vulnerable and you guys
shared what you guys have gone through
and so
it and it does take strength and it does
take you know
it does take a lot of strength to be
able to do that
um 10 sisters are rare as you know
um so that's that's not something you
find every day so we are brought at a
level of uniqueness
um by having a variety of opinions
between siblings because we do share so
many different personalities I obviously
probably have seen Brenda so it's
maneuvering our way through that and
just again being a united front and
remembering what we stand for our family
motto which is family about everything
well you guys do a good job and I look
forward to watching the rest of the
season and hopefully we'll see you guys
back in season two oh very much from
your lips to God's ear thank you so much
Brenda I appreciate that